so und jetzt schalten wir gleich weiter
nach erfurt zur thüringischen
gesundheitsministerin heike werner
größte sie ganz herzlich und morgen
erstmal die frage haben sie noch
impfstoff in thüringen oder ist er schon
aus wir haben noch impfstoff
zum einen weil wir natürlich die zweite
du es ist zurückgehalten haben wir das
gemeinsam mit den ländern vereinbart
haben und es die möglichkeit gibt durch
verschieben von dem zweiten termin und
auch mit dem neuen modernen stoff hier
ist unsere zusagen was impftermine
angeht auch einzuhalten aber langsam
wird es knapp und das ist für uns denke
ich das wichtigste heute nachdem ins
gipfelt dass wir das die genauigkeit
haben was die liefertermine angeht damit
ihr auch weiter in china vergeben können
und eben keine absage ja es gibt ja gute
nachrichten das ein bisschen aufgestockt
wird hier und da bei den liefern
bei den lieferanten aber der
bundesgesundheitsminister sagt schon mal
bitte nicht so hohe erwartungen was ihre
erwartungen an den gipfel heute drei
erwartungen
das habe ich schon gesagt wir brauchen
genauigkeit was die liefertermine angeht
und der sind denke ich die hersteller in
der pflicht uns heute hier entsprechende
ansagen zu machen und zum zweiten geht
es mir darum zu schauen braucht es
unterstützung also müssen wir schauen
wie wir hier in deutschland hersteller
unterstützen was kann deutschland die
eingestellte europa unterstützen aber
ich habe auch noch eine dritte hoffnung
dass wir endlich aufhören uns
gegenseitig die schuld zuzuweisen weil
ich glaube dass dieses dass wenn wir
darin hängen bleiben
das nicht dazu beitragen wird dass wir
die akzeptanz erhöhen wir vermittelt
gerade den eindruck hier sein wo chaos
noka es das nicht ist wird gehen
menschen werden geschützt und das ist
das wichtigste dass wir am ende
transparenz habe dass ich am ende gibt
bescheid wissen dass wir gemeinsam uns
so in der öffentlichkeit auch äußeren
und das mit akzeptanz und transparenz
für dem ziel nämlich endlich die
pandemie zu überwinden das können wir ja
also das heißt sie beteiligen sich nicht
an diesem schwarzen peter gerede gibt es
aber an ihrer partei muss man ja sagen
die linkspartei schon auch vertreter die
diese schuldzuweisungen den ganzen tag
immer
wiederholen das bringt uns nicht weiter
haben sie gerade gesagt was bringt denn
weiter schauen wir mal nach thüringen
die frage ist natürlich in den
vergangenen wochen immer wieder präsent
gewesen warum sind die zahlen in
thüringen so extrem hoch gelaufen
ja das hat viele gründe zum beispiel
wissenschaftlerinnen inzwischen davon
aus im vergleich zur bundesrepublik sehr
sehr niedrige instanzen und faktisch ist
jetzt der herbst winter erst die zweite
welle für thüringen
wir haben sehr viel ältere bevölkerung
hier haben hier eben noch keine
infektion in den größenordnungen
durchgemacht die haben viele
pendlerinnen und pendler die nach
thüringen kommt und natürlich gibt es
auch eine gewisse sorglosigkeit also
damen der ersten welle sozusagen mit
einem glimpflichen endlich davon
gekommen ist er ist zum teil auch die ja
ich sag mal die diese ratlosigkeit einen
bestimmten stellen eben auch relativ
groß gewesen aber dass jetzt die
ernsthaftigkeit von vielen erkannt wird
sieht man daran dass die zahlungen auch
wirklich signifikant sinken was die
infektion angeht und wir hoffen dass
dieser trend beibehalten bleibt wir
wissen aber auch dass es für jeden
einzelnen und vor allem auf fehlen die
menschen die als familie den betroffenen
sind aber auch für die unternehmerinnen
unternehmen eine große herausforderung
ist ja ich bin selbst ein bisschen
erschrocken wenn man heimatkreis die
nachrichten aus dem eichsfeldkreis mit
den zahlen die mag man gar nicht glauben
was sind denn jetzt die rezepte gewesen
die dazu geführt haben dass die zahlen
tatsächlich sinken und sinken sie denn
auch beständig zum einen welche gerade
von ihrem landkreis gesprochen haben
wir haben natürlich noch der eine
unbekannte die uns momentan wirklich
große sorgen bereitet es sind die
mutationen auch in thüringen kann mich
jetzt mutationen festgestellt und unter
anderem auch im eichsfeld und jetzt ist
eben die frage wie schaffen wir das
wirklich einzuschätzen und schnell
unterbinden dass diese höhere
ansteckungsgefahr geben
position verbunden wird dass wir unsere
erfolge jetzt wieder zunichte macht
ansonsten haben wir uns sehr streng an
die beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidenten-konferenz gehalten
also es heißt es gibt bei uns
beispielsweise eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre es gibt die strenge
kontakt beschränkungen wir haben relativ
zeitig angefangen die kindergärten und
schulen vor dem harten lockte die
bundesregierung gemeinsam mit den
ministerpräsidenten beschlossen hat
tatsächlich schon zu schließen und es
ist denke ich auch die sensibilität die
jetzt nochmal gestiegen ist die dazu
führt dass sich menschen daran halten
kontakte zu beschränken und damit die
infektion auch zu minimieren denken
weiteres wichtiges thema ist die
sensibilisierung der unternehmen und
auch hier stellen wir fest dass gerade
unternehmen selber noch mal versuchen
armee home office auch zu ermöglichen
und b auch mit testen und ewig jetzt
risiko zu minimieren
da gibt es aber große unterschiede das
ist auch klar das sind denke ich einige
der punkte die dazu geführt haben dass
jetzt wirklich die infektion sinken
wir hoffen dass es kontinuierlich so
weitergeht wir sind sehen aber auch dass
gerade die anderen bundesländer die
nicht von seinem hohen niveau gestartet
sind jetzt zum teil in bestimmten
infektionszahlen auch noch hängen
bleiben und ich hoffe dass wenn wir alle
sehr achtsam sind und uns ein käfig zu
regeln halten
denn auch weitere die infektionszahlen
sich minimieren werden
ministerin was es gerade angesprochen an
die mutation wie weit sind sie denn oder
wie umfangreich kontrollieren sie das
dann testen sie das denn dass sie den
überblick haben wie die mutationen
tatsächlich unterwegs sind und welche es
sind momentan bei uns nur die britischen
banken also b 11 7 aufgetaucht und ja
wir haben natürlich ein schönes gleichen
probleme gibt es deutschlandweit haben
dass diese spezialisierungen hier so
bisher nicht durchgeführt worden aber
wir haben gute möglichkeiten dass unser
universitätsklinikum beispielsweise kann
dieses vorgehen wir haben große labore
in der lage sind mehr sequenzierungen
vorzunehmen und man merkt
daran dass jetzt die mutationen
auftreten und dass wir sie jetzt dass
wir wissen dass sie auftreten das liegt
eben daran dass jetzt mehr
diese spezielle untersuchung der proben
auch vorgenommen wird das ist wichtig
dass es notwendig damit man auch
erkennen lernt wie die mutation sich
verhält und es gibt bei uns jetzt auch
schon
gerade da wo er sehr dynamisches
ausbruchsgeschehen hatten beispielsweise
in bestimmten pflegeeinrichtung noch
eine spezielle suche danach ist das
vielleicht auch hintergrund gewesen dass
es nur mutationen eine rolle gespielt
hat wie sind die ansteckungswege unter
umständen gewesen das muss jetzt noch
viel intensiver natürliche untersucht
werden damit man sehr schnell ausbreiten
unterbinden kann
da wünschen wir in eine gute hand gutes
gelingen und da sind wir alle daran
interessiert dankeschön fürs gespräch
nach thüringen heike werner